seguro que lo habrás escuchado miles de
veces el dólar es la moneda hegemónica
en el mundo para ese amigo inteligente
que todos tenemos lo que en españa'
llamamos el cuñado la supremacía del
dólar es clave para entender la política
mundial hay una conspiración mundial
pero mejor así hay una conspiración
mundial para que eeuu mantenga ese
hegemonía a toda costa iluminar
nuevo arte
pero si quieres dejar a uno de estos
expertos en geopolítica en la evidencia
sólo tienes que hacerle una pregunta qué
significa exactamente que el dólar sea
la moneda hegemónica es decir que gana
eeuu con el hecho de que su divisa sea
la más utilizada en el mundo de verdad
estamos hablando de algo tan relevante y
lo que es más importante qué pasaría si
un día el dólar perdiera esa hegemonía
podría reemplazarlo alguna otra moneda
el euro o el yuan chino hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
los que lleváis tiempo suscritos a
visual política sabéis que argentina
está en una situación muy delicada y
necesita pedir dinero prestado a los
inversores internacionales verdad en
estos casos lo normal es emitir un bono
de deuda es decir un papelito que dice
si tú me das equis cantidad de dinero yo
te la devolveré en diez años junto a un
porcentaje de intereses hasta aquí todo
bien
[Música]
pero imagina esta situación nosotros le
prestamos 3000 pesos argentinos al
estado argentino ahora mismo estamos en
2018 esos 3.000 pesos argentinos
equivalen a unos 100 dólares
estadounidenses pero qué pasará en el
año 2028 es muy probable que la divisa
argentina se haya podido devaluar aún
más en otras palabras que para el día en
el que argentina nos devuelva esos 3 mil
pesos es muy probable que no nos sirva
ni para comprar una bolsa de doritos en
el supermercado por eso los inversores
internacionales que son muy listos le
dicen a argentina vamos a ver yo te
presto el dinero no te preocupes que yo
te lo presto pero esa deuda me la vas a
denominar en dólares en dólares
estadounidenses
es decir que yo te presto 300 dólares y
tú me devuelves otros 300 dólares de
esta forma nos protegemos de las
posibles de evaluaciones pero he
esperado un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de argentina en realidad la
mayoría de los
es eligen el dólar como moneda de
referencia para emitir su deuda y por
eso seguro que todos habréis leído
noticias como esta en los periódicos
financieros
el gobierno federal emite nuevo bono
global en dólares a plazo de 10 años y
como os podéis imaginar no sólo hablamos
de gobiernos por ejemplo cuando arranco
que es la petrolera de arabia saudita
vende su zumo de dinosaurio a mexico les
diferents
para el carro donde vas tú con esos
pesos mexicanos que no sé ni lo que
valen no no no no no tu me pagas en
dólares que me dan mucha más confianza
si mis queridos amigos de visual
política si todo el petróleo que se
mueve por el mundo se compra en dólares
estadounidenses y casi toda la deuda
pública que se emite en este planeta
también eso explica que el 60 por ciento
de las divisas de reserva extranjera que
tienen los bancos centrales estén en
dólares estadounidenses
[Música]
en el mundo hay más de 167 billones de
dólares en circulación y más de la mitad
de estos están fuera de los eeuu no
existe ninguna ley internacional que
diga que el dólar tenga que ser la
moneda de referencia pero sin embargo
casi todo el mundo confía en esta divisa
para el comercio internacional pero
ahora os preguntaréis y esto para qué
sirve
es decir que gana eeuu con que su divisa
esté circulando por todo el planeta pues
depende si eres una empresa o un
ciudadano particular estadounidense te
resulta completamente irrelevante es más
incluso podríamos decir que es un
problema ahora bien para el gobierno de
eeuu la hegemonía del dólar es como un
regalo caído del cielo porque ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
por un puñado de dólares os lo hemos
dicho mil veces aquí en visual político
lo peor que le puede pasar a un país es
tener hiperinflación es decir que de la
noche a la mañana los precios de las
cosas se pongan por las nubes
[Música]
y porque surgen las hiperinflaciones
pues en la mayor parte de los casos este
fenómeno ocurre cuando un banco central
se pone a imprimir billetes como si no
existiera mañana pero la pregunta es por
qué es decir por qué se devalúa una
divisa cuando imprimimos demasiado para
entender esto tenemos que pensar que la
moneda de un país es un producto un
producto más que se rige por los mismos
principios que el petróleo las naranjas
o los teléfonos móviles oferta y demanda
[Música]
por ejemplo la demanda del bolívar
venezolano es bastante limitada solo los
venezolanos lo utilizan así que si el
banco central de venezuela se dedica a
imprimir muchos bolívares o dicho de
otra manera a aumentar la oferta
monetaria es normal que el precio baje
es decir que la divisa se devalúe sin
embargo la demanda del dólar
estadounidense es nacho vidal jana no
para de crecer todo el mundo en todo el
planeta lo utiliza eso significa que la
reserva federal tiene un margen enorme
para poder imprimir billetes sin que el
dólar se devalúe
y os preguntaréis para qué quiero
imprimir billetes la reserva federal
pues vamos a poner un ejemplo vamos a
imaginar que le hemos prestado 100
dólares a la casa blanca y que llega el
momento en el que nos los tienen que
devolver así que llegamos al gobierno
estadounidense y nos dicen claro que sí
hombre faltaría más a ver cuánto te debo
100 dólares sin problema mira que te vas
un momentito al edificio sed al lado hay
que poner reserva federal- y te lo
imprimen en el momento a esta práctica
la llamamos monetizar deuda y si cuando
le hablas de estas cosas a vuestro
cuñado oa ese amigo inteligente que
todos tenemos probablemente se os quede
mirando con cara de tonto lo cierto es
que está hegemonía del dólar permite que
eeuu se pueda endeudar con muchísima más
comodidad que cualquier otro país por
eso si leéis prensa económica os podéis
encontrar fácilmente con titulares como
éste
la crisis de la deuda americana se
acerca los pagos de intereses llegarán
al billón de dólares anuales hasta qué
punto es bueno que eeuu pueda tener
tanta deuda en este otro vídeo os
hablamos más a fondo sobre este tema
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando con
todo lo que acabo de decir podréis
pensar que eeuu es tan irresponsable
como venezuela o argentina verdad pues
por supuesto que no veréis todos los
bancos centrales del mundo imprimen
nuevo dinero todos los años y no sólo
hablo de imprimir billetes también
hablamos de generar dinero de forma
electrónica la diferencia está en las
proporciones en este gráfico podéis ver
el aumento de la oferta monetaria lo que
podemos conocer como el indicador m2 en
este caso de la reserva federal
estadounidense como veis el número de
dólares aumenta año tras año pero qué
pasa si lo comparamos con argentina
creo que ya podéis ver la diferencia
y si lo comparamos con venezuela
[Música]
en fin creo que sobran las palabras
verdad en sólo nueve años venezuela ha
multiplicado por cien por cien su masa
monetaria mientras que eeuu ni siquiera
ha llegado a duplicarlo
y como curiosidad os diré que he quitado
a propósito el año 2018 porque si no el
gráfico se salía de la pantalla este año
el banco central de venezuela ha
multiplicado por más de 4000 su masa
monetaria y precisamente esta es una de
las razones por las cuales el dólar
estadounidense es la moneda más
utilizada en todo el mundo porque es una
de las más estables es decir que
mientras otros bancos centrales se
dedican a imprimir dinero a diestro y
siniestro la reserva federal es
razonablemente responsable y ya sé lo
que estáis pensando qué pasa con las
otras divisas como el franco suizo o la
libra esterlina
si hay una divisa estable en el mundo
ese es el franco suizo verdad pues
tenéis razón es más atentos porque esta
es la parte del vídeo que os va a
sorprender aunque el dólar sea
importante no es ni muchísimo menos la
única divisa de reserva en el mundo
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
un mundo multidivisa lo hemos dicho al
principio del vídeo el 60% de las
reservas de divisa extranjera que tienen
los bancos centrales en todo el mundo
están en dólares dólares estadounidenses
pero os preguntaréis y qué pasa con el
40% restante la segunda moneda más
utilizada es el euro que representa un
20 por ciento de las reservas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
le siguen la libra esterlina y el yen
japonés pero no son las únicas muchos
bancos centrales tienen reservas
denominadas en dólares australianos o
incluso en francos suizos aunque son
monedas poco comunes son reconocidas por
ser muy estables y os preguntaréis si lo
importante de una divisa es que sea
estable porque no se utiliza el
franco-suizo tanto como el dólar
[Música]
la respuesta es que hay muchos menos
francos suizos en el mercado pensadlo
bien suiza tiene ocho millones y medio
de habitantes
eeuu tiene trescientos eso significa que
el banco nacional suizo- necesita
imprimir muchos menos billetes recordáis
que os decía que en el mundo hay unos
1,67 billones de dólares pues los
francos suizos ni siquiera llegan al
billón es decir que es mucho más difícil
encontrar francos para hacer una
transacción por otro lado eeuu es el
mercado más grande del mundo
eso significa que miles de empresas de
todo el planeta venden sus productos en
este país
ah
imagínate que eres una empresa mexicana
y vendes un teléfono móvil en eeuu como
te pagan pues exacto con dólares
estadounidenses y qué haces con esos
dólares los cambias a tu moneda local y
quién se queda con tu dinero exacto el
banco mexicano donde has hecho el cambio
es decir que cuanto más comercia eeuu
con el mundo más dólares circulan por el
planeta dicho de otra forma el dólar es
una moneda estable abundante y sostenida
por la economía más grande del planeta
hasta hace décadas ninguna otra divisa
le hacía competencia pero el mundo está
cambiando a estas alturas creo que ya os
podéis imaginar lo que os voy a contar
al principio del vídeo os decía es
posible que el dólar pierda su hegemonía
o que al menos deje de ser tan
importante como lo es hoy en día y la
respuesta es que sí
mientras eeuu se vanagloria del américa
primero el resto del mundo mira a otro
lado os lo estamos contando todas las
semanas aquí en visual político donald
trump quiere proteger a eeuu del mercado
internacional su primer movimiento fue
cancelar los acuerdos de libre comercio
con la unión europea y asia después
introdujo los aranceles al acero que han
servido para que empresas como harley
davidson se marchen del país esto os
hemos hablado también hace muy poquito
en este otro vídeo
[Música]
también ha anunciado que quiere terminar
con el nafta tlcan que es el acuerdo de
libre comercio entre estados unidos
canadá y méxico en otras palabras que
los eeuu de donald trump quieren
aislarse del mercado internacional
quieren comprar menos cosas al
extranjero y eso qué significa pues
significa que el extranjero tendrá menos
dólares y a eso le tenemos que sumar
noticias como esta
los bancos centrales en europa están
empezando a reemplazar sus reservas en
dólares por joanes chinos o esta otra
rusia planea una venta de bonos
denominados en yuanes chinos ante la
amenaza de sanciones pero no se
emociones todavía si es cierto el joan
chino también conocido como renminbi era
una divisa prácticamente inexistente en
el mercado internacional se utilizaba
únicamente dentro de china sin embargo
en los últimos años parece que se está
empezando a tener en cuenta como divisa
de reserva pero eso no significa que de
la noche a la mañana todos los bancos
vayan a cambiar dólares por yuanes en
realidad hay muchas incógnitas sobre el
yuan chino incógnitas que vuestro amigo
listillo vuestro querido cuñado seguro
que no conoce pero no os preocupéis
porque en las próximas semanas sacaremos
una continuación de este vídeo así que
ya sabéis suscribiros a visual político
y no os olvidéis de darle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones
[Música]
mientras tanto os voy a dejar con estas
preguntas creéis que el dólar será capaz
de mantener su hegemonía en las próximas
décadas si no fuera así que otra moneda
podría sustituirle
el euro el beat coin podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre si os gusta este proyecto y
queréis apoyarnos también podéis visitar
nuestra página de patrón si habéis
disfrutado de este vídeo dadle a like
compartirlo con vuestros amigos y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto chao
[Aplausos]
[Música]